[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi nous on nous allons
parler d'insertion professionnelle sans
oublier bien sûr notre module sur les
entreprises qui recrutent
tout de suite le sommaire le plan local
pour l'insertion et l'emploi existe
depuis 20 ans à saint quentin en
yvelines comment fonctionne ce
dispositif qui peut en bénéficier
réponse dans cette émission erwan le
gala délégués communautaires à l'emploi
et à l'insertion professionnelle nous en
dira plus sur cet accompagnement qui en
sait en partie par les fonds européens
focus sur une entreprise d'insertion est
long pour 3 1 sert trop spécialisées
dans les espaces verts s inscrit dans
une démarche économique sociale et
solidaire en recrutons des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
enfin si vous êtes en recherche d'emploi
ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises de notre
territoire qui rôdent sept conseillers
bancaires à la banque postale ou encore
mécanicien au sein du groupe d'abord à
pau roanne et de quoi noter aider les
personnes les plus en difficulté à
s'insérer durablement c'est l'objectif
depuis 20 ans du pli financé par saint
quentin en yvelines et le fonds social
européen ce dispositif d'accompagnement
renforcé est destiné aux personnes de
plus de 26 ans plus de détails dans ce
reportage
en ce mois de mai saint quentin en
yvelines se met à l'heure européenne
l'occasion pour les habitants d'en
savoir plus sur les dispositifs financés
par les fonds européens en particulier
le pli quatre lettres désignant un
dispositif qui est chaque année plus de
500 saint quentinois le pli c'est donc
un dispositif qui permet en fait
d'accompagner des personnes sont en
grande difficulté pour les amener
jusqu'à l'emploi pour entrer sur le
dispositif il faut résider sur les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
sur les sept communes initiales pour
l'instant on n'est pas étendu à 12
il faut être bénéficiaire des minima
social que ce soit la ss le rsa pour
avoir un aussi un critère de grandes
difficultés parce qu'on peut en effet
avoir des ressources autres mais avoir
des difficultés de logements familiaux
de santé qui permettent en entrée sur le
dispositif
les bénéficiaires doivent également être
inscrits à pôle emploi depuis plus de 12
mois
beaucoup ont déjà eu des expériences
professionnelles qui a eu un accident de
parcours qui font qu'ils se sont
éloignés de l'emploi et du coup après ça
nous permet ensuite de travailler pour
retourner vers l'emploi
ludovic est artiste et il est suivi
depuis deux ans par le pli grâce à ce
dispositif il a pu trouver un logement
et ainsi envisager plus sereinement une
carrière professionnelle parce que m'a
apporté le pli c'est beaucoup d' écoute
une écoute une écoute honnête frange
sincère personnalisé sur le côté pérenne
et bien j'ai pu signer un contrat de
location de tableau que je renouvelle le
voilà tous les six mois
en parallèle aussi j'ai pu suivre une
formation de cinq mois en tant que adf
c'est-à-dire de vie aux familles même si
je suis encore professionnel dans le
métier artistique et on additionnant les
deux jeux peut sereinement aborder
n'importe quel projet maintenant dédié
aux personnes de plus de 26 ans le plan
local pour l'insertion et l'emploi
affiche un taux de sorties positives de
plus de 50%
alors est-ce que ce dispositif va
évoluer c'est ce que nous allons va voir
avec erwan le gall un entretien
enregistré à l'hôtel d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les images
sont signés patrick jette de disques
smit erwan le gall bonsoir un jour vous
êtes délégué communautaire à l'emploi et
à l'insertion professionnelle à saint
quentin en yvelines alors le pli le plan
local pour l'insertion et l'emploi a été
mise en place il y as j'entends puis son
anniversaire cette année
première question est ce qu'on peut déjà
faire un bilan depuis son existence
depuis sa mise en place
alors un bilan depuis longtemps je n'ai
pas élu en tout cas le bilan qu'on peut
faire c'est que nationalement lorsqu'on
compare les résultats du pli nous
n'avons pas à rougir
super repli avec des résultats en sortie
positive à plus de 56 %
donc ça c'est une vraie réussite et puis
évidemment c'est un outil incontournable
pour l'agglomération
je rappelle à l'époque cette commune et
sommes toujours dans ce périmètre de
cette commune puisque nous sommes à 12
communes mais les engagements avec
l'europe nous ont mis sur un périmètre à
cette commune dans wii les résultats
sont très favorables 56% est ce que
c'est satisfaisant est ce qu'on peut
mieux faire
on peut toujours me faire toujours mais
oui c'est satisfaisant parce qu'on sait
que c'est un public qui est très très
éloignées de l'emploi en avant dans
l'insertion redonner confiance en soi
repartir après aller chercher un travail
en cdd en cdi ou sur des stages c'est un
travail de longue haleine 1
et oui je trouve que ça quand c'est pour
cent c'est bien d'ailleurs si on ramène
ça au coût de fonctionnement par à par
bénéficiaire eh bien nous sommes à des
coûts qui sont assez bas
oui c'est quelque chose qui me réussit
en chiffres aussi un peu plus de 500
personnes c'est ça chaque année qui sont
accompagnés ou alors on est 1 500
d'année dernière détient 518 personnes
en file active parce qu'après faut bien
dissocier des files actives mais sorti
les rentrées mais dans l'accompagnement
oui c'est ça nous sommes à plus de 500
personnes
alors le plus on en parle également
aujourd'hui parce que nous sommes en
plein mois de l'europe et donc c'est un
dispositif qui est financé en partie par
le fonds social européen
il a été financé depuis ses débuts par
oui oui oui hélas actuellement nous
sommes toujours moi je veux vraiment ce
que je maîtrise à 100 en 2014 et 2020
c'est un fonctionnement à 50% c'est à
dire qu'un euro engagée par saint
quentin en yvelines c'est un euro
engagée par l'europe
voilà ça coûte combien ont tous et 1940
2000 euros donc 50% saint quentin et 50%
sur sur l'europe
il faut savoir qu'il ya des axes 1 c'est
pas de l'argent leur père ce point des
fonds européens qui arrivent comme ça et
nous avons une enveloppe bon bah c'est
soit ordinaire pour cette commune nous
avons la moitié de ces gras de 1000
euros nous allons faire plein de choses
dont on a des axes précis on doit rendre
des comptes avec beaucoup de précision
voilà donc nous avons une articulation
qui doit se faire et d'ailleurs nous
avons le troisième axe sur les trois
axes le troisième est vraiment lié à la
coordination des deux autres axes parce
que nous devons rendre compte avec des
stats
et puis surtout ils veulent aussi une
réussite et d'ailleurs
les fonds européens sur l'ensemble du
territoire ces quelques millions et je
crois que même avec le feder et le fse
journée on avoisine les 5 milliards
c'est aussi avec des belles réussites de
sortie voilà vous le disais il ya cette
commune qui sont qui sont concernés par
ce dispositif quelles sont-elles c'est
connu alors c'est les 17 communes
historique
bon je vais je peux vous les citer de
mémoire mais là quand les sept communes
on est les saints qui ont qui sont venus
se greffer pour faire les deux nouvelles
pc 2016 n'ont pas encore le droit mais
on a une réflexion pour 2020 si on
s'élargit ou pas avec les deux communes
donc ça veut dire que une personne qui
ne fait pas partie des 17 communes en
fait ne peut pas profiter de pour
l'instant en tout cas ne peut pas
profiter des domiciliés sur une des cinq
autres communes à ne veut pas en
bénéficier
alors on parle d'évolution est ce que
justement c'est un dispositif qui va qui
va évoluer dans son fonctionnement
peut-être sûrement dans les prochaines
heures il a dit j'ai alors dans son
fonctionnement je ne sais pas au niveau
des axes oui on a des orientations cette
année plus précisément on à la station
pour les femmes que je suis très heureux
qu'il y ait eu cet axe là de porter
parce que c'est vrai que après beaucoup
de beaucoup d'analystes on s'est rendu
compte comme que les femmes qui étaient
très loin de l'emploi
beaucoup plus de mal à revenir à
l'emploi que les hommes pour plein de
choses
eu égard à l'or alors maternité alors
gestion des enfants donc c'est des
choses la vie d'une femme c'est
compliqué et devait on se devait jeu
vraiment et ça je suis très fier d'eux
accompagné ou encore plus voilà donc oui
on doit évoluer et puis je pense qu'on a
évolué avec la société on doit évoluer
aussi sur l'actionneur on va il ya le le
point sur la formation et l'ouverture
avec les entreprises
donc on doit aussi créer du lien avec
les entreprises qui existe parce que ils
font un travail formidable clients
vraiment mais on doit encore plus
articulé l'insertion désacralisée voilà
je pense que oui on doit se moderniser
de ce point de vue là alors juste
dernière question questions pratiques si
les saint quentinois qui nous regardent
sont intéressés justement pour profiter
de ce dispositif comment font-ils pour
pour avoir plus de renseignements lors
des deuils pour être éligible il faut
être sur pôle emploi est trop demandeur
d'emploi depuis plus de deux mois voilà
bénéficier bénéficie aussi du rsa sans
notre aide et autres - via la plateforme
internet de 50 ha voilà où il y a
le site je crois c'est plié on va
afficher le mais il faut déjà être très
très loin de l'emploi vraie dynamique
d'emploi n'est pas éligible au pea
merci en tout cas pour ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes délégué
communautaire à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines chercher et à
saint quentin en yvelines à certaines
entreprises ont fait le pari de recruter
des personnes en insertion c'est le cas
d'un serpro basé à elancourt reportage
christophe à 30 ans après de nombreux
stages et petits boulots il vient tout
juste d'intégrer l'équipe d'un serpro
une entreprise d' espaces verts basé à
elancourt une véritable opportunité
puisque ce contrat d'ouvriers en
insertion va lui permettre une
reconnexion durable avec le monde du
travail
la semaine s'est bien passé
j'aime ce que je fais travailler en
extérieur donc ça me plaît donc ce jeu
la motivation de lire chaque matin un
serpro intervient sur tout l'ouest
parisien pour des entreprises des
promoteurs ou encore des agglomérations
particularité de cette structure depuis
près de 40 ans recruté en majorité des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi
seuls les encadrants sont en cdi une
démarche économique et sociale et
solidaire et personnes en insertion ont
un contrat de quatre mois jusqu'à deux
ans maximum et dans ce laps de temps ont
la possibilité de faire des formations
qui vont les aider à être employables et
vont pouvoir être intégrer plus
facilement dans la vie active
un peu triste de voir à la fin des deux
ans que le personnel qu'on l'informé
s'en va et moins apprécié le but
danseurs pros aussi c'est qu'ils
retrouvent du travail après qui s'insère
dans la vie professionnelle et en
général c'est une réussite actuellement
sous le statut d'association interpro
pourrait évoluer en coopérative est
ainsi étoffer son personnel à présent si
vous êtes à la recherche d'un emploi
prenez de quoi noter voici plusieurs
offres proposées par deux entreprises
situées sur notre territoire pour bien y
goûter ses responsables ressources
humaines du groupe la braquo aujourd'hui
nous avons plusieurs offres d'emploi à
pourvoir donc duché visite du s'est dit
également du contrat d'apprentissage les
campagnes de recrutement sont et seront
également ouvertes
donc au niveau des postes donc nous
recherchons un technicien sav
ile-de-france donc sur la partie
nettoyage sur la partie et stagiaires
nous allons rechercher un mécanicien
sédentaires ou plutôt en atelier donc
l'idée c'est de réparer
des tondeuses et du matériel agricole
notamment ensuite nous avons plusieurs
postes en apprentissage également à
pourvoir
donc si vous êtes intéressé n'hésitez
pas à nous envoyer votre candidature est
donc vos cv lettre de motivation en
précisant pour quel poste vous citez
candidate est donc l'adresse et drh
@ la baraque au point comme bonjour je
suis thibault chalmel le drh du réseau
et de la banque postale dans les
yvelines et le val d'oise la poste est
connu et reconnu pour sa politique qui
privilégie la formation et l'évolution
professionnelle des postiers mais ça ne
suffit plus aujourd'hui à répondre à nos
besoins de développement la banque
postale recherche ainsi 500 conseillers
bancaires dans toute la france entière
dans les yvelines et le val d'oise à
saint-quentin ici à versailles à
sartrouville à cergy pontoise et bien
d'autres villes
nous proposons 25 emplois en cdi pour
des conseillers bancaires et conseiller
spécialisé en patrimoine
les candidats devront justifier d'un
diplôme de niveau bac +3 en banque
assurance et d'une première expérience
commerciale réussie dans le secteur
j'invite tous ceux qui souhaitent nous
rejoindre à se porter candidat sur le
site la poste recrute point fr où ils
retrouveront toutes nos offres d'emploi
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi et 12
juin pour un mode d'emploi consacrée aux
jobs d'été
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]